siete pronti a rivedermi con quel sacco
dell'immondizia al posto di questo
vestito bellissimo l'estero a un fame 10
10 e testa di cazzo chi è quello c'è un
team non me lo ricordavo mai che c'è un
tipo così era quella roba lì non si
strozzo
è sempre quello è
porca [ __ ] e va bene
anche io mi piaccio le movenze di mia
nonna è madonna chiede riflessi che ciò
io veramente ragazzi faccio nvidia in
invertebrati comunque ragazzi quello è
un hayter spiegami qual è il tuo
problema che faccio le views che brucia
al culo è che faceva di testa di cazzo a
due iter ma come cosa macrozone
ipantellas la cos'è sta roba
spiegami no vabbè erano parole ma cosa
vi ho fatto solo perché faccio tante
views vi rode il culo e cazzi vostri
scusa mettiamola su gli haters che
sempre ecco quelli erano altri youtuber
famosi e niente rosicavano fra te e ti
ammazzo ti ammazzo la famiglia di
capirlo ti ammazzo potessi attaccarti la
febbre attraverso il monitor a tutta la
tua stirpe attaccherei che non è caduta
tra quante cazzone ahimè se voi
spiegami ok popoli si è posizionata una
merda di trappola ho preso a faccia a
salgo di sopra sai che li sopra perfetto
e bellissimo come tikal all autostima
perché tranquillo che tanto non ci
venivo da sopra conte non ci gioco con
te dicevo ragazzi e bellissimo come i
creatori del gioco vogliono prenderci
per il culo e riescono a creare nelle
trappole che riescono in pieno a
prenderti per il culo fantastico
questo posso godere io da 1 a tua madre
dimmi che era uno di quei due stronzi
almeno ma quanto ti adoro ragno del
cazzo bene devo sfuggire però vero
picchia infame pure il ragno è fino
all'ultimo quanto mi deve seguire esso
bellimbusto il cazzo faccio quadro già
lei o non ci arrivo e va beh siamo io
contro ii the strong non ci credo non ci
credo ha funzionato veramente che culo
vai vai ma zio e zia mezzi menzione ho
fatto l'ho provata non posso morire
adesso non posso morire adesso fatto
provare la propaggine la propaggine è
caduto qui devo questa nuova c max o no
no no frate frate
cazzo
a me la [ __ ] cosa ho fatto signore cosa
ho fatto non ho capito neanche
fantastico comunque sono io è riesco a
fare cose
nessun altro su youtube riesce a farle
iscrivetevi ma perché alla fine quei due
sono morti ecco lo sapevo io lo stato
basta quanto vivi se sta roba
lo prendo ma tu anche così devi pagare
il cazzo spiegami 23 fammi sentire
quanto sei contento 0 allo spin go lo
spingo lo stupro simulando un ragno con
una gamba sola vale veramente ma davvero
0 a merda ancora vivo è anche anche da
morto adesso carica pista con le braccia
tutti e due
infami due esseri umani siamo solo noi
in questo posto ci vogliamo puoi fare la
guerra
lo sapevo devo farlo roteare ci mancava
solo che faccia micro al ponte
quella non è maionese ragazzi sicuro beh
questo succede ai ragni che mi danno
fastidio nella vita comunque che serva
da lezione a tutti quanti i ragni che
vogliono cagarmi caso in futuro guardate
questo video e lasciate dislike se siete
ragnick e bottiglie ci sono delle
bottiglie nel limbo capiscono nelle
bottiglie di plastica serio non ho visto
l'acqua sono un collega possa essere un
[ __ ] qual è il mio problema nel non
vedere le cose
[Musica]
fate
c'è un sacco di gente annegata e non
capisco il perché ma va bene perché
quello c'è una roba in testa cos'è e
sempre al ragno che ti ha va beh sono
zombie anche questi no perché quello 6
suicidato in un metro d'acqua spiega
frate dobbiamo fare a cazzotti ti devo
fare il culo
cosa fai prove mi schiaccia come tocco
terra lo so io non posso lanciare
qualcosa mi chiamato la tua madre batte
forte sempre come unieuro zio ma ma
mappa pesante proprio a bonetto problema
di vita la fionda poiché 6 bart simpson
devo fare sicuro ma sicuro lo sapevo che
devo sacrificare un morto neanche pace
all'anima sua ragazzi tanto se ne è
andato svendite che cordì leone quel
tizio mi spiace frate o muori da
leggenda o vivi tanto a lungo da
diventare una sottiletta sempre così non
erano bottigliette vicolo siano larve a
capisco chi si così lanciano le larve di
che cosa serve quindi sono le larve che
ipnotizza la gente a nola l'ammazzano
direttamente ok dove oltre tutto sto
casino non fare pura che devo fare pure
attenzione alle larve ma magari se
riesco a captare ma mezza volta un mezzo
tranello sarebbe anche utile che dite
arca [ __ ] laida io pensavo che fosse
quello il tasto per attivare il coso non
il resto ma vabbè quanto ci fate che in
realtà adesso il tasto è e quello lo
sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo porca eva lo
sapevo che è nervoso e mi danno sti
giochi come che quando vedo dei morti
spero sempre che siano quei due
cerebrolesi di prima
vabbè
c'è più forza nei polmoni mio nonno
cazzo non si è offeso sia offeso basta
penso a loro non lo sanno
porca eva mi ero preso porcaccia vacca
volevo buttarmi ho capito cosa devo fare
comunque una cagata
e poi tra l'altro il primo inciampo e
muore per un [ __ ] apocalittico marca
eva e juan erano l'altro no ah sì anche
l'altro ciao zio later se questo
significato di schiacciare gli hater
comunque lasciamo perdere tutto sto
casino
andiamo avanti stato per dunque il tipo
che si è suicidato all'inizio lo merita
tutta la mia stima ai complimenti tutti
bravi con la cerbottana finché non avete
la mamma e acqua quest'anno si capite
nebbia c'è nebbia nel limbo non si
capisce se acqua o meno pochi ragazzi
credo stia diventando un po incasinato a
livello di enigmi questo è pesante
sicuro perché c'è un carrello dove ci
sono i carrelli e videogiochi io non ci
metto ora a capire che il caso devo fare
andare avanti
so che fare non devo andare avanti
mandare di sopra solo che se mi
arrampico la liana inutile ho capito
quindi questo così è che cazzo serve il
carrello ok non ho capito cosa serve il
carrello ragazzi prove ah ok perfetto
che è culo ma mi è andata bene che l'ho
capito al volo sono concas ok bene
meno male che sono alto un metro e un
tic tac e ragazzi mania di comandare i
bambini nei videogiochi del genere è
sempre servita perché sono nano e passo
ovunque eccola la pizza con i funghi che
servono al limbo e questa cosa fa ma al
contrario cos'è sta roba
quindi alla fine quindi non ti ammazzano
tifano ti fanno rincoglionire le larve
ok non sto andando dove marcava che
brutta cosa mamma mia e ho capito quando
scava di più cambi direzione ok perfetto
io devo fare le cose prima che cambi
direzione ok quindi adesso devo andare
dall'altra parte della della caccia
prima che cammini lezione che cambia
cambia ok
vai vai vai silenzio spingi spingi eva
pure lento cazzo avranno la spinge ok
adesso la spinge a sei scemo salta
veloce più affamato di una ragazza col
ciclo andiamo avanti ragazzi con che ho
capito che le larve ho capito il
funzionamento delle larve l'importante
questo attenzione che
quando vedo io quando vedi ingranaggio
cose così mi spavento perché sono iniqui
giganteschi e io già non capisco un
cazzo figuriamoci porca eva se quella
roba una rana non arrivi ai funghi a
tranchino ti faccio male tesoro vieni
vieni vieni non ti facciamo a lerici
passiva la prendere
e vabbè ma non ti faceva male zia o la
gente mi segue per uccidermi o scappa
perché ha paura che lo uccida io non
voglio far niente a nessuno quanto è
complesso sto enigma mi spaventa così ok
quindi devo tirare sull'acqua per far
galleggiare il tronco come la tiro
sull'acqua non lo so il nostro capendo a
ok mi chiama non pensavo di poter
saltato sopra ma dai ma che strano
quindi faccio uscire e quella schiaccio
com cazzano così presa perché ti sei
aggrappato devo schiacciarla bisogna
fare ma forse non devo schiacciarlo solo
spingerla che sono sempre sa di questi
giochi è tutto presa l'hanno presa a
fango dai vieni dai massei seria
ok va bene ma non avevo capito mai nella
vita
e vabbè porca eva tutto sto bordello per
un po d'acqua va bene se domani piove
ragazzo stato io
io sono stato giuro ok perfetto
la vita mia
una rana è stata in grado di far piovere
bye bye bye bye bye bye zio vai zio
veloce perfetto sono fatta ragazzi non
so come ma va bene ho fatto io ho dovuto
far piovere per passare un attimo
pensato fosse un altro ragno mi stavo
pagando in mano non ce ne sono più di
rai ministro gioco vero che ovvio io
parlo sempre io devo sempre parlare
sempre devo parlare porca eva non so mai
zitto mai quanto ci scommettete momeni
spunta uno gigantesco perché ho detto
sta roba
cos'è ad altri enigmi ragazzi cos'è sta
roba
non vediamo degli scatoloni così grossi
dai tempi dell'ikea ragazze e keira la
leva che serve sta roba scusami
non ho ben capito che se restare o no
[Musica]
capisco non capisco però va bè questo
devo fare credo di aver che credo di
aver capito ragazzi credo
e va bene sul veloce veloce veloce
veloce madonna quanto sale l'acqua
perfetto e giusto e dove il tory a
dovrebbe essere giusto ragazzi non lo so
è in teoria ci sono le spine ma dovrei
riuscire a passarlo stesso
dai dai dai dai dai 0 dai zio teddy oh
yes ma si blocca un continuo ancora
l'acqua fammi capire non fossimo ancora
veloce veloce veloce veloce quarto
continua pre bucata sta cosa quindi
affonda affonda cazzo ci arrivo non ci
arrivo sarà scemo
[ __ ] a dai vero fatto uno spazio
che palle madonna se non ci arrivi
micali schiaffi che volava calcarono
ragazzi con primi episodi di limbo spero
che vi sia piaciuto come sarebbe
piaciuta il documento mi piace anche ai
vari social come video totale
descrizione un bel like perché è morto
il ragno e [ __ ] quello ci siam
tolto e vabbè ma nel problemi di
possibilità di ci sarà anche di peggio
purtroppo se siete vicini diavolo
possiamo vito belle ragazze